I believe too few serious scholars are
studying the social impact of computers
the way they affect us as individuals in
groups and in society at large as we
learn as we work and even as we play now
that's strange to me because here we
have the most powerful tool mankind has
ever known and we've hardly begun to
analyze how it is affecting us let alone
how it is shaping us and how we can
shape it so that we get what we want in
the way of effects Lise prowl is one of
those few individuals who has devoted
her entire professional life to this
all-important area after 15 years as a
professor of Social Sciences at CMU
she's now professor of management at
Boston University and she's published
seven books and many research papers in
this area and it's a special pleasure
for me to have someone address this key
topic someone who's devoted her entire
life to it Thank You Lee
I feel so old
I'm not a computer science pioneer I
hope that was at least implicit in what
Andy said although some of my best
friends certainly are for the past 25
years I have been pleased and privileged
to be an observer of the community
making parts of Bush's vision real when
Doug was talking yesterday about how
human systems and computer tools need to
evolve together
I was actually reminded of one of my
early experiences as a user of this
technology in 1977 I'm trained as a
sociologist my doctoral dissertation had
absolutely nothing to do with computing
but I typed it on an alto computer at
Xerox PARC I printed the final document
on ears and I think there may be a few
people in this room who know about ears
one of the earliest laser printers I
collected the signatures on the
signature page of my dissertation I took
my dissertation to the registrar's
office at Stanford to be certified bound
blessed what at whatever it is that
happens to these things now this was in
the days when the production
requirements for dissertations were
extremely stringent the requirements
specified a certain kind of rag paper
black carbon ribbon no erasers so I
handed in my thesis my laser printed
thesis the dragon lady in the
registrar's office flipped through the
pages ran her fingers over the words
fixed me with a steely eye and said you
can't turn this in it isn't the original
I was highly evolved my computing tools
were highly evolved for that time but
the social system in which I was doing
my work had a ways to go still true
today I'm delighted to be here to
celebrate the technology vision that
that that we are all pleased to honor
actually though mostly what I want to do
is talk about the human vision or models
of human beings that are associated with
Busch's technology vision and also other
visions that that we're hearing about
today every technology vision that
really captures people's imagination is
it accompanied by a view of human beings
using the technology who they are what
they do how their lives are changed
improved we hope by the technology the
human vision that is associated with the
mimics with Bush's paper is a view of
the person working alone could I have
the first slide please
working alone not doing housework or
manual labor but doing intellectual work
the technology of course is envisioned
to support that solo work to make it
more productive to make it even more
creative now in Bush's paper we have
evoked the view of the scholar seated at
a wonderful desk interacting with the
world scientific literature alone
Licklider in his 1960 paper man-machine
symbiosis evokes a view of the scientist
or an engineer solving problems more
productively with a machine doing the
clerical and mechanical activities the
scientist or engineer is alone with the
machine alan kay evokes a view of a
person of any age especially a child
interacting with a dynamic medium for
creative thought a Dynabook to work and
play more productively and creatively
alone
now of course we have to note that Doug
Engelbart has always been the exception
to this fairly common view of the human
being associated with the personal
computer as early as 1968 of course he
was describing computer support for
people working together sharing files
working in real time meetings this
technology vision of personal computing
of course is extraordinarily important
extraordinarily worthwhile
there's a whole lot more to be done etc
etc etc but science and Bush after all
was speaking about the scientific
community science and most other
productive work in modern society is
inherently a social enterprise but over
the next slide please
lick was an empiricist and therefore
dear to my heart he reported real data
in his 1960 paper he reported in fact
that 85% of his thinking time thinking
time was devoted to clerical or
mechanical activities searching
calculating plotting transforming he
used his data on human behavior data on
himself but still data on human behavior
to justify his technology vision what he
didn't point out though is that while
85% of his thinking time was devoted to
clerical or mechanical activities
probably only 15% of his day was devoted
to thinking the rest was probably spent
in meetings
you've been there face-to-face
interaction with other human beings I
don't mean only formal meetings
conferences symposia hallway
conversations count as well there have
been many many time allocation studies
of people working in a variety of fields
including scientists bench scientists
technical supervisors and managers
people across all of these studies all
of this kind of work spend between 50 to
85 percent of their day in meetings and
in addition to that they spend some
fraction of their alone time recovering
from meetings I I mean doing follow-up
work but I guess there's other kinds of
recovery too let me give you just some
more evidence and reminders of something
that we all know very well that science
is a social enterprise one indicator of
growth in team size over time it took
two people to build the first airplane
it took seven thousand three hundred and
two people to build the Boeing 777
author lists for papers and journals
have certainly been growing over the
years in the past 40 years the mean
number of authors for papers published
in scientific journals across all
disciplines has doubled the mean number
of authors per paper in 1955 was 1.8 in
1994 was 3.5 last year in 94 there were
more than 700 papers published in
scientific journals that had more than
5500 authors listed on the title page
the I think records so far last year the
two top quark papers two papers
announcing the discovery of the top cork
last year each listed over 400 authors
on the title page now even in academic
computer science
computer science is not known as a big
science field the mean size of work
teams is increasing if you look at the
Proceedings of SIGGRAPH the computer
graphics conference the mean number of
authors per paper at SIGGRAPH in 1975
was 1.7 in 94 it was 2.4 if you look at
the ACM computer Chess Championship the
mean number of people associated with
the winning program from 75 to 80 4 was
to the mean number associated with the
winning program from 85 to 90 4 was 3.8
these are fairly formal indicators of
the fact that science is not a solo
enterprise here's a livelier one this is
from Lois Thomas's description of the
Marine Biological Laboratory at Woods
Hole a human institution that as Lewis
Thomas says is possessed of a life of
its own with an extraordinary influence
on the growth and development of
biologic science Lewis Thomas suggests
that to learn more about the Marine
Biological Laboratory you might begin at
stony Beach he says it's the most minor
of beaches hardly big enough for a
committee but close enough to the
laboratories so that the investigators
can walk down for a sandwich lunch with
their children on sunny weekdays on
weekends in hot midsummer it is so
crowded that one must pick ones way on
tiptoe to find a hunting place but there
is always a lot of standing up anyway
biologists seem to prefer standing on
beaches talking at each other
gesturing to indicate the way things are
assembled bending down to draw diagrams
in the sand by the end of the day the
sand is criss-crossed with a mesh of
Ordnance abscissas curves to account for
everything in nature you
and hear the sound from the beach at a
distance before you see the people it is
that most extraordinary noise half shout
half song made by confluent
simultaneously raised human voices
explaining things to each other now
that's what science is about personal
computing fortunately has evolved to
allow interpersonal communication to
allow people to explain things to each
other to talk with each other using
computers could add the next slide
please
you might just do a little thought
experiment what would the world be like
today if there were 100 million personal
computers and no interactive
communication no ability to contact
people or create and sustain human
relationships with other people through
these machines actually I'm not sure we
would be having this meeting I don't
mean just we wouldn't have gotten the
logistics of it organized I'm not so
sure we would be here to celebrate the
way the vision has come to be played out
of course we shouldn't feel sorry for
Bush that he didn't predict the power or
importance of interpersonal
communication in the context of his
technology vision he's in good company
not only the history of personal
computing but even the history of
computer communications features
technologists who underestimated the
lure and importance of human
communication using this technology
everyone in the this room is familiar
with the ARPANET and email story in fact
some of the people in this room were
were the heroes or villains or something
in that story but the conventional
wisdom anyway has it that the ARPANET
was conceived to link computers and of
course we all know it turned out to link
people to initially through email
distribution lists and bulletin boards
populated by members of the same
intellectual community
who were housed in a small number of
universities industrial labs a fairly
homogeneous bunch of folks truth to tell
although they might not be pleased to
hear me say that more recently as
Internet access has soared the human
links have been formed through
mechanisms like news groups or Usenet
groups that are populated by people who
may have absolutely nothing in common
with one another except for internet
access and a shared interest in the
topic of the particular group commercial
electronic services providers like
CompuServe and prodigy also didn't
anticipate the importance of the human
communication services like email chat
rooms now scientists certainly don't
just process information alone in their
offices moreover they don't just
communicate either generically they do
these things within social contexts that
is through multiple ongoing
relationships with other people and
organizations I must say I've been I was
I have been struck by the serious
observation made by all the speakers
thus far that people are important and
social issues are important and I'm I'm
very obviously I'm glad too glad to hear
the speakers say that but there's a sort
of funny gap between how the previous
speakers talked about people by which
they mean individual human beings who
speak into a microphone or type with
fingers on keys or whatever and society
which is big forces that are good or
evil or something that they're huge
there's a there's a very large middle
ground that's very important and it's
the middle ground where most of the
productive work gets done in society
through multiple ongoing relationships
with people and organizations could have
the next one each relationship every one
of them is structured by roles roles
have formal responsibilities and
obligations associated with them norms
accepted rules for behavior each
relationship is shaped through
reciprocated action of people working
together each relationship is sustained
through trust trust by the way doesn't
have to mean liking but sustained
through trust obligation and affiliation
now people may complain that they spend
too much time in meetings often because
meetings aren't always an efficient
information exchange mechanism but you
know information exchange isn't the only
reason for going to a meeting or for
participating in an ongoing social
context people like to talk with other
people people go to a workshop even when
the papers are online showing up
signifies the importance of the occasion
and the importance of the community let
me give you an example of a scientist
doing productive work through multiple
ongoing relationships and by the way I
apologize for the sort of wishy-washy
relationship word I couldn't figure out
a nice crisp alternative so we're gonna
have to go with it think of a scientist
at the weekly meeting of his research
group who's critiquing the research
presentation of one of his doctoral
students this scientist is
simultaneously helping to create new
scientific knowledge perhaps describing
additional analyses that the student
could do in order to refute the claims
made by a competing lab in addition
reminding the student to verify the
analytic techniques he's just been
describing with the new postdoc who has
recently arrived
from a colleagues lab where these
techniques were first developed that's
one thing that scientist is doing
helping to create new scientific
knowledge at the same time the scientist
is training the next generation of
scientists through suggesting the
additional analyses through perhaps
critiquing the format of the student
slides through asking the student to
present his results in the professor's
graduate survey course helping to create
new scientific knowledge training the
next generation of scientists deciding
which of his colleagues labs to
recommend as a good postdoc placement
for the student when he finishes his
thesis deciding which journal to submit
the students research to and remembering
that he still owes the editor of that
journal reviews on three papers thinking
about how these results are going to
affect the next round of studies and
deciding he's going to have to apply for
new fund sooner than he had hoped
realizing that he's going to have to say
yes to the Provost's request that he
chaired the university Task Force on
graduate education if he's going to have
any hope of getting the Provost to
approve his request for additional lab
space now the manna-fest task when we're
thinking about this scientist scientists
manifest task is to critique a research
project but all of the other tasks are
equally necessary to being a productive
scientist they all entail information
processing absolutely but each of these
information processing tasks is embedded
in a particular social context a
particular structure social structure of
reciprocal human interdependence a
structure that's sustained through trust
obligation and affiliation furthermore
the contexts the scientist is operating
in simultaneously operate at different
levels of social aggregation let me see
if I can explain a little bit what I
mean by that could Ivan
next one please the social enterprise of
science operates at three levels of
aggregation at the institutional level
we have the human conventions and
organizations that certify knowledge and
allocate resources we have the Nobel
Prize committees we have the scientific
journals with their editors and
editorial boards we have the research
funding agencies at the middle range we
have the distributed colleagues and
competitors working in a single area
these play themselves out in conferences
summer studies postdoc exchanges
preprint mailing lists the third level
of aggregation is the close in level the
day to day interaction with colleagues
and students this is the place this is
the level of aggregation where the
apparatus is built where the
measurements are taken where results are
initially puzzled over and discussed and
where the next generation is socialized
this is also the place where as some
people would say if you don't have to
get on an airplane to go somewhere this
is where you go
the close-in level the productive
scientist has to work simultaneously at
all three levels of aggregation and has
to manage information process
information and manage relationships at
all three levels so what can we say
about what computer support for
interdependent actors looks like today
what are the systems and applications
that acknowledge interdependence next
slide I think the big success stories
are electronic mail and file transfer I
don't know if there's anyone in this
room who would think they're glamorous
or represent research frontiers for
today but they certainly in terms of
numbers of people who use them to get
productive work done are this
says stories unstructured general tools
people can and do use them in any social
context well probably not yet to the
Nobel committees but to most other
social content in most other social
contexts they require very little social
and cognitive overhead to use but of
course they're just the beginning of of
what we need what are people working on
today I don't I feel a bit audacious
telling this audience about what
computer scientists are doing today but
I think some of these kinds of work are
not ones that would be particularly
visible or perhaps even particularly
interesting to you so let me let me just
say a very brief word at the other end
of the spectrum from unstructured email
and file transfer is workflow something
that unfortunately business
organizations are quite enamored of
today I don't want to dwell on it but it
it does acknowledge interdependence it
does things like attempts to automate
things like administrative processes
like travel requests or payroll or some
business processes like approving loan
applications the focus is is actually on
it's sort of a transaction processing
thing the focus is on the flow of
transaction tasks across processors some
of the processors may be human beings
but the focus isn't at all on all of an
individual human beings responsibilities
obligations and tasks as they're
structured in roles in an organization
another kind of work that a bit of which
is going on today there's something
called CSC W which stands for
computer-supported cooperative work and
there's group where support for people
allegedly support for people doing
intellectual tasks
and the term was CSC W the the acronym
was created I think in 1986 so this is
certainly not an old and venerable
subfield but at any event some of the
examples of things that people are
working on include working with shared
files shared design spaces shared
document editors group awareness tools
group meeting rooms to support
face-to-face meetings or geographically
distributed meetings now typically in
much of this work the focus is on a
small group I suspect a part of the
reason is it's sort of hard enough to
get the technology to work for a small
number of people I'm not I'm not clear
that people working in this area believe
that the small group is the only useful
or important level at which people do
work but at any event much of the work
going on now focuses on groups from size
say two to ten also much of this work
takes a single task focus for instance
there's work on the task of
collaborative design
there's work on the task of
brainstorming in meetings the these
applications are often highly structured
they may force people to state
assumptions or to specify commitments
and to state their binary choices you're
either in a meeting room or you're not
you're either present for the video
conference or you're not you're either
explicitly making a commitment or you're
not I think that computer support for
the productive scientist who doesn't
just process information but who works
through relationships with other people
in organizations needs to have a whole
different flavor could I have a next
slide please
it shouldn't just support a
tasks a manna-fest task because the
scientist of course is doing multiple
different tasks simultaneously only one
of which is the manifest one it should
not just support a group because a
scientist is simultaneously
participating in multiple groups at
different levels of social aggregation
so what should this computer support do
it should support the scientist who
works in multiple groups simultaneously
who works at different levels of social
aggregation simultaneously it should
move with the scientist as he or she
physically and cognitively moves from
group to group throughout the day and it
should allow the scientist to map his
information environment to his social
contexts not to arbitrary physical
locations like a meeting room or
temporal constraints now since I'm not a
technologist it would be extraordinarily
silly for me to tell you what the
technology should look like instead what
I'd like to do is describe some social
facts that if we had technology support
for them could lead to more productive
behavior your assignment is going to be
to invent the technology to support the
social facts let me offer you three
examples could ever the next one first
social fact collection of social facts
has to do with the absent meeting
participant people have multiple ongoing
responsibilities their responsibilities
obligate them to participate in
particular real-time meetings
conflicting obligations mean that not
everyone who should attend a given
meeting will be able to do so in fact
I'll bet that every
you who is sitting in this room today is
missing one or more meetings back in
your home spot that you should be
attending I think we need technology
support for the partially present
meeting participant now I have to tell
you I've been in a number of meetings
where people in the room we're partially
present but that's not what I mean
what I mean is for the person who should
be at the real-time meeting but can't be
there should be easy ways to review the
meeting after the fact and I think
actually in Raj's videotape of earlier
today I caught a glimpse of how that
might be able to happen but that's only
half of the story that's good for the
person who can't be at the meeting but
for the people who are present at the
real-time meeting it should be just as
easy for them to signal the attention of
an absent member as a present one to ask
questions of the absent member at
particular points to request action the
only difference will be that the
partially present participants will be
delayed for a bit so I hope you can
invent technology support for the
partially present meeting participant
second social fact the meeting isn't
over when it's over most meetings are
embedded in an ongoing social context a
meeting doesn't end when it's over
people figure out after they walk out
the door what they wish they had said
they think of new ideas to contribute
they do what they said they would do
during the meeting or they don't and
they have to be reminded and so I want
you to invent technology support for the
post meeting meeting after the
face-to-face meeting is over it should
be easy for participants to slide new
ideas insights clarifications
contributions into the ambient
information environment of the meeting
these could be from fully present
participants or partially present
participants
third social fact group membership is
dynamic groups add new members these
members not only come with a different
set of skills which presumably is why
you put groups together in the first
place but they also arrive with
different obligations different ways of
doing business bringing a new member up
to speed is necessary for the member to
function productively in the group and
for the group to function productively
creating a new group is simply a special
case of adding members to an initially
empty group I know that Marjorie
Blumenthal had been invited to attend
this meeting and was unable to be
present Marjorie
runs the panels that are associated with
one of the National Academy of Sciences
committees and I think Marjorie would
particularly have will particularly
appreciate your invention of technology
to support the dynamic group member
technology to support adding members to
an initially empty group the process of
convening these advisory committees is
one that she certainly handles with
expertise but it takes a lot of time and
energy the rest of us who have to
convene groups of people from time to
time I think could certainly appreciate
that so what would technology support
for the dynamic group member look like
well one of the things that we certainly
would want to have is a who are these
people
button when a new person enters a group
he or she can easily learn about the
accomplishments skills social circles of
other members and vice versa
of course it'll be easy to go deeper if
you wish by reading papers or examining
other work products that are referenced
in the first level of the who are these
people display so that's one one piece
of it second piece is automatic
configuration of group communication
protocols now Nick was telling us this
morning that in some number of years
we'll be able to shake hands and all of
that stuff will pass automatically
that's one way of doing it I guess I
don't know that I always want to shake
hands with everybody but it would be
nice to have other way well would be
nice to have other ways maybe that
computers without having to get your
hands involved could exchange
information about email addresses video
conferencing connections the conventions
for producing work products that each
individual person brings with him or her
into the particular group what versions
of what software do people use I don't
know maybe in the future there won't be
versions but I sort of think there will
be and all of that information should
get exchanged automatically that's
automatic configuration then there
should be easy ways to configure at
least some of the relationship protocols
which I mean by that how open or closed
is the group when and in what form can
its work products be sent outside the
group our drafts confidential can drafts
be circulated to colleagues outside the
membership for the particular group who
needs to who must review work products
before they can be shared more broadly
who's in charge
what's the calendar now
these are Dizzy's I think that's a
technical term and I hope it's clear
that I'm not I'm not asking you just to
build
Dizzy's kind of the next slide please
these are just examples of what we could
hope to find in a technology that
supports a scientist who is not simply a
solo information processor not simply a
generic communicator to the galaxy but a
person who works through simultaneous
relationship structured relationships
with other people and other
organizations I also hope it's clear
that my vision will require new social
inventions - for example the partially
present meeting participant is a social
role we'll have to develop norms and
beliefs about this role ways of ways of
proceeding the who are these people
button requires I can imagine this being
used with Aveda for academic people but
for non-academic people people who do
not work in an academic organization we
need useful ways of summarizing a
person's accomplishment skills social
circle and so on let me although I have
explicitly tried to focus on science and
the doing of productive scientific work
I'd like to look beyond that domain for
a moment and suggest that technology
that can support scientists who already
are working in multiple simultaneous
relationships may also support people
who need but do not have a multiplicity
of ongoing relationships many human
beings are physically alone or feel
socially isolated they perhaps could
benefit from having more people in their
ambient information environment some
Usenet groups as I suspect all of you in
this room know already serve this
function to some extent
for some people today there's a
newsgroup or listserv for practically
every malady or misfortune of the human
condition and some of these have been
extraordinarily important in the lives
of people who participate in them now
technology to support the dynamic group
member could be used to help manage
electronic support groups support for
the post meeting meeting could be useful
perhaps after a parent-teacher
conference when the parents think of
additional questions they should have
asked during their 15 minutes allocated
with the teacher support for the
partially present meeting participant
could be useful for someone who is
unable to attend a spouse's medical
appointment but who needs to be involved
in the treatment plan I think that the
vision of the solo individual made more
powerful more creative more productive
through technology will continue to be
beguiling seductive important
fundamentally important new inventions
for personal computing based on that
vision will and should continue could I
have the next slide please
what I've been trying to do though is
ask you to think about how the person
embedded in multiple social contexts can
be made more creative and more
productive perhaps the real challenge
for the web is to support social context
through socially structured information
I think that the challenge for
technologists more generally is to
invent support for people who are not
just information firm ation processors
not just generic communicators but who
are embedded in and accomplish work
through interdependence with other
people thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much folks question time
let's see can we have the house lights a
bit so that Lee can see you Michael
Garrison Keillor writes about the rise
of the feeling that as computer
technology means that interaction at a
distance replaces or supplements
face-to-face interaction the personality
type that I guess we associate with
automobile salesmen will become less
important in society and the type
associated with the WIMP sitting at a
typewriter will become more important
and dominant do you think this is
accurate or that anything like it will
happen actually I've I've done some
research documenting the rise of the
shine and since I am one of those folks
I'm delighted to report that computer
communication does in fact bring with it
benefits for folks like me I guess
though I think we'll always still have
automobile salesmen so I don't see it as
one becomes more influential or present
and one less I don't see it as a zero of
some game necessarily nor do I think
that real human beings are going to stop
talking to real human beings
face-to-face let's do it Stewart card as
communication technologies as
communication becomes easier with larger
and larger numbers of people around the
world and in fact as we succeed in being
able to collect more and more
information from the net and and so on
the there's more stuff to do but the
amount of time somebody has remains
constant so the real issue one of the
real issues seems to me the man is the
management of attention among all of
these things so can you conceive of ways
to support the scientists to get less
communication or to have more time
one of the things more solo no no Stu
yeah I didn't make my point clear the
scientist doesn't do science solo the
scientist does science in a socially
structured group and the group may be
able to figure out ways to sustain its
boundaries so that information isn't or
stuff data isn't totally totally swampy
I think that graduate students are
wonderful information filter retrieval
devices for professors and I don't want
to propose that we get rid of them or
replace their functions with computing
technology I really was trying to make
the point that if you if you try to
invent technology for the solo
information processor or the generic
society you miss out on a lot of the
helpful stuff that that social
organizations are already doing for us
structuring people's attention already
and providing mechanisms and roles for
helping manage information flow Samuel
add up Stein with Sense Media we operate
something called the sprawl over little
year-and-a-half ago we took some
technology developed at Xerox PARC
called lambda mu and we modified it
enhanced it that's what we call it some
people think we defiled it to support
hypermedia
by adding support for hypertext and
being able to inline graphics and things
like that and right now as a result over
a year and a half we now over 4,000
people on our server and Hawaii and it's
been called a collaborative hyper media
server and it integrates together text
and graphics and chat and mail and news
posts and what I'm wondering is if
you've done any research into some of
the social interactions that are going
on there it's a it's a very rich and
diverse society with a bunch of people
really working together all over the
world to create
hypermedia presentations and this
technology is now spreading out into
lots of servers all over there's some
stuff being done at Brown University as
well I was wondering if you studied any
of these new societies that are starting
up they're mostly populated with people
under the age of 20 but they're doing
some incredible work and let's see the
short answer to your question is no I
haven't yet studied these communities
I'm certainly looking forward to doing
so I mentioned when I was talking about
the inventions that I hope you folks
will will do the fact that there have to
be new social inventions as well and at
the moment I'm not sure that we have
good social inventions for how to have
4,000 people work together productively
on anything people that you're
describing are doing that invention now
at the same time you're inventing or
modifying or whatever the technology
tools so I look forward to having the
chance to try to systematically
understand some of these kinds of things
that are going on however let me let me
return for a moment to productive
science whereas there may have been 400
authors on the top quark papers there
certainly were 4,000 people involved in
in some way the production of the
research that led to those papers and
those organizations are highly socially
structured and I think it would be
interesting to learn from how to take
the best of how those organizations work
and lord knows they do not work
perfectly but to take the best of that
and to try to understand how that can
also be useful in your kind of new world
Ron Ron Becker University of Toronto
we I'd like to thank you for a very
interesting presentation and it it
strikes me though that scientific
communities in general are resistant to
understanding and appreciating and
believing in the social context of
science and I go back to Bush I mean it
strikes me that he probably should have
seen some of that in in terms of the
Manhattan Project which was sort of one
of the first examples of sort of big
science and I wonder whether first of
all you agree that the communities are
resistant to to believing this and
appreciating this and why why this is is
it's something about the way we educate
scientists or or whatever I think thank
you for the thank you I think it's
partly a function of how we educate
scientists I think it's partly a
function of how scientists are there is
a it's important that there be a hubris
that there that there be a belief that
that the solo inventors thinker can
change the world usually doesn't work
out but you have to have that belief
it's fundamentally important to the
survival of the scientific enterprise so
I'm not discouraged or unhappy when I
see that it's it's natural I must I
think that often as scientists filled
with hubris age they they come a bit
more to appreciate the importance and
necessity of the social structure and
the social enterprise that supports
their work unfortunately that sometimes
happens too late for them to then
proselytize for the funding of social
science research
there's a book that I always like to
take inspiration from on a to combat the
the solo scientist that's the book by
Bruno Latour science in action
many of the other scientists have given
that too to read love the book but when
they get back to their own academic
departments and start considering merit
and promotion they always look for the
solo contribution and they they have all
sorts of ways to dig and see if they can
find it so we really do have a kind of a
contradiction between where your heart
wants to go your heart wants to to
appreciate the social context and but
when you put it in action you want to
find the solo invent their contribution
again I don't have any suggestions on
how to change that no and I don't think
actually that that we need to worry
about changing that I think what you
need to do is continue to push to invent
the technologies to invent the
technology environments that will make
it obvious to one and all that
scientific collective work is where the
productive work of science occurs but
you know again I go back I don't want to
stamp out hubris I mean it's kind of
obnoxious in faculty meetings but it's
very important for the scientific
enterprise to continue question for you
you've named a few names that are more
on the solo inventor side what are some
of the names that you would hold up as
examples to look at for some of the
other parts that you were talking about
there for example work flow or CSC
w-well Doug Engelbart Doug Engelbart and
Doug Engelbart
to begin and I hope you heard that I
that I did acknowledge him initially all
the work that all of the people in
computer communications and shared files
are doing today I since I'm not a
technologist I never feel the need to
put down anybody's stuff I say yeah do
more of that but let's do some other
things too I I want to expand your world
not stamp out some things but let's add
more people and more ways of thinking
about inventing technology support for
interdependent people thank you
getting hungry what's been really fun
about this symposium for me is that I've
been able to introduce so many insanely
great people in the words of the late
great Steve Jobs and certainly one of
the very top most of those people is
Alan Kay most of you identify him with
personal computers and personal
computing and at a time when that idea
was still embryonic or as some of us
thought lunatic fringe he's made seminal
contributions to object-oriented
programming
graphical user interfaces and window
managers via the small talk language and
it's programming environment he's always
been interested in the appropriate use
of computer technology and especially in
the area that appeals most to me
education Alan is also as most of you
probably know a very serious musician
was a professional musician and I tried
to characterize him first thought of him
as a polymath but many people don't know
what that is so then I thought about
interdisciplinary in' and alan didn't
like that so we came up together with
calling him alan what was the word
trance
and then we had to fish for that chance
ooh so trans everything that I know
about here is Alan to finish up for us
thanks thank you
we had to use the trans prefix somehow
since Ted is here well I thought when I
was thinking about what to what to do
for this talk I thought it when I keep
when I kept on thinking back to the
period when I think that Bush was most
influential in the in the ARPA world and
I was thinking that it would might make
a nice talk to just think about the 60s
just to cut it off at the end of 1969
before it just happened that 1970 is
when Xerox PARC started up so cut it off
before Xerox PARC and when I was
thinking back the the more I thought
back the more I thought of some of the
interesting people who influenced that
very very interesting an exciting decade
so I thought to start off with a little
little trip down memory lane and as a
kind of a context for the for the talk I
thought I'd start off by showing you
arthur Kessler's Arthur Kessler is a was
a great novelist who in the last years
of his life became a science
psychologist we doing research in
creativity at Stanford
and one of his characterizations of
creativity sort of goes as follows he
said that our minds are kind of
constrained to think within context or
within systems of belief sometimes
they're called paradise but he was
thinking of something perhaps larger
that we have a
a set of common sensical things that we
accept as reality and our thought
patterns sort of jog along staying in
this particular here a pink plane every
once in a while we have little outlaw
thoughts that are regarded as lies by
the pink plane and they're usually just
suppressed and pushed back and every
once in a while when you're taking a
shower or out jogging or something you
are relaxed enough to let one of these
outlaw thoughts flourish a little bit
and sometimes what you find out is that
that little pink idea when expanded into
the blue context is much more
interesting than it was in the pink
context so the idea here is terrific
ideas often hide behind good ones good
ones are the ones that are reckless is
like peer review at NSF
they always fund good research but they
almost never fun great research because
somebody has already six people are
trying to decide whether what you're
trying to do is reasonable ahead of time
and usually the way it works is you
decide whether it was reasonable by
looking what happened so and then
Kessler said and what happens when you
get one of these big blue inspirations
no sorry today well I goofed I left out
a slide so I'll just tell you here he
said there are three reactions if you
were telling a joke then the reaction is
ha ha if you are doing science then the
reaction is a ha and if you're doing art
then the reaction is ah
because he points out in each of these
cases for instance a joke is something
that takes you down a garden path and
then suddenly reveals that the context
you're in is not the one you thought
you're in science has this aspect as
well you suddenly see it was there all
the time and often besides saying aha
you start laughing and of course in art
the whole idea and art is to try and
take you out of the world that you're in
your commonplace world and reveal that
there's more to the world and one of the
Maxim's here is that knowing more than
your own field is really helpful in
doing this and I've always thought that
one of the reasons the 60s was so
interesting is that nobody was a
computer science scientist back then and
everybody who came into it came into it
with lots of other knowledge and
interests then they tried to figure out
what the computer what computers were
and the only analogy place they had to
use for analogies where other areas and
so we got some extremely interesting
ideas from that and of course the reason
being educated is important is simply
because you don't have any blue context
if you don't have any other kinds of
knowledge to think with so engineering
is probably is one of the hardest feels
to be creative in just because it's all
about optimizing and you don't optimize
without being very firmly anchored to
the context that you're in so what we're
talking about here is something that
it's not about optimization but actually
in kind of rotating the point of point
of view now I didn't I was 5 years old
in 1945 and I must have seen the life
magazine article because I used to peel
through Life magazine but in that age I
was much more interested in the manila
envelopes that life came in because you
could draw in them so I don't I'm sure
that mimics made no impression on me
back then I ran across it when reading a
science fiction story by Robert Heinlein
in the 50s and Heinlein had this nice
thing of taking terms that he had found
out about and making them generic so he
spoke rather casually in the science
fiction story of a mimics and whenever
he did that I had found out that that
was a good reason to go to the library
and trying to find out what what basis
Memex had that brought me to reading
Bush's article in the in the 50s and I'm
ashamed to say that it aside from being
interesting in the science fiction way
it made nowhere near the impression on
me that did on Doug Engelbart and some
other people it wasn't actually until
after I had met Doug Engelbart and had
heard him talk that I realized that the
the the ideas of Bush had tremendous
significance but I got that through the
through the eyes and the ideas of Doug
Engelbart so for me I started off in the
very early 60s 1961 doing data
processing for the Air Force and back
then they didn't really have operating
systems they're very ad hoc an Air
Training Command had many bases and they
had to move files around and somebody to
this day unknown I once tried to find
out who it was that thought up this idea
had come up with a wonderful notion for
allowing data to be used from base to
base without having to have lots of
standards and formats and operating
systems and the way it worked was this
is that each file on the Burroughs 220
tapes had three sections the first
section was a set of pointers into the
second section which was a set of code
and the code knew about the third
section which was the format's of the
data records so in modern terms
what you have here is a generic
interface a set of methods and then the
data parts of objects does the first
example that I know of in which this
object-oriented idea was actually used
of course it wasn't thought of in those
terms back then but it was a it was
something that was used quite a bit in
the airforce until they decided to
standardize on COBOL in which case all
of this stuff got thrown out and they
went back to processing data another
thing I saw that didn't make an enormous
impression on me in fact I should say
the other thing that happened was is
that the the third machine I learned
down here in the Air Force was the
Burroughs be 5000 which I think has
seven of the ten best software ideas
directly in the hardware and at that
time I only appreciated a couple of them
the fact that it was very easy to
compile to was pretty much all I
understood about that machine but it
also had something like this technique
of being able to deal with state
indirectly they could do all the things
that you're normally used to doing with
bits but without having to know what the
bits look like or where they where they
were I didn't appreciate that at the
time in 65 I was actually helping to
debug the control data 6600 which is my
vote for the first RISC machine it was
about 1965 it was a ten MIT machine with
the kind of instruction set and parallel
operations that we associate with RISC
machines today and while I was working
on that machine at Seymour craze Lab I
read this article first article by
Gordon Moore showing what had been
happening in integrated circuits up to
1965 and then he up to that point it had
been doubling every year and so his
first cut at it
was what if it kept on doubling every
year yeah so that was interesting to
think about but from my standpoint I
really couldn't make any extrapolation
or jump from this freon cooled 6600 that
could detect how many people were
actually in the room at a given time
because of the capacitance on its doors
from human beings move moving around to
what this might might actually mean a
couple years later Gordon Moore looked
at it a little more closely look at the
physics of the silicon and said well it
probably won't be worse than a factor of
two every two years so that's that lower
less sloped line and just for interest
the what actually happened from about
1970 on is that magenta lying there it's
an interesting thing about Moore's law
was it was actually a 30-year prediction
and at least the one that he did in 1967
or 68 or so he was able to bracket
successfully what was going to happen
exponentially in silicon for about 30
years quite a remarkable almost
unbelievable and I think that most
people in the industry that we're going
to be affected incredibly by it couldn't
believe it at all at the most they
thought it might mean that they would
have more margins on their mainframes
but the idea that this might mean
millions and millions of computers I
don't think affected anybody at the time
including including Gordon Moore but
when I went to University of Utah so did
by an accident
first person I ran into is Dave Evans
the head of the department and the this
that's referred to there was Ivan
Sutherlands thesis he had a stack of
these Brown theses from Lincoln labs on
his desk and he had to take one of these
and go away and read it before you got a
desk and I must say I didn't really
understand sketchpad very well but it
seemed to be about a system that was not
just about making drawings that was an
idea I hadn't really thought about
either back then but it was also the
idea that the drawings generally had
meaning especially in engineering and
what you would really like to do with
these most of the drawings you make in
engineering is to see whether they
actually work so the underlying notion
of sketchpad in fact it was conditioned
by the fact that the display on the TX 2
at Lincoln lab which was a machine by
the way about the size of this room
maybe a little larger you just seen one
small part of it here the display was so
bad that it had discouraged previous
people who had been asked to do computer
graphics on it and the difference here
was that Ivan looked at this terrible
display and asked the question we should
all ask more often which is what else
can it do and when he thought about it
he realized that although the pictures
are going to be terrible and the
drawings done by the plotter were not
going to be up to engineering standards
that what else it could do was to
simulate and this is an idea that was
not strongly in any of Bush's writings
in spite of the fact that he was one of
the developers of early analog computers
which in fact did simulate and of course
he had funded Aniak which simulated up
to a certain point but if you look in
his writings you'll see that he thought
that certain logical reasoning would
eventually be able to be done by
computing and he had some real jumps as
far as transcribing speech but the
notion of being able to deal interacting
actively with simulations was not
something that was really in his in his
writing he was something this was an
idea that came about from other people
and I thought just for the fun of it
to show you the movie one of the movies
made the summer or the late summer of 62
first set of movies made of sketchpad
and
in reviewing this there's one one place
on the tape where there's some some tape
damage so let's we'll just ignore that
as we go along let's let's roll that
first tape yeah so you dip the light pen
into the ink and there's rubber band
technique Ivan invented and why they
called it sketch pad is that you could
put in something very quickly and
loosely and then give it some rules and
here the rules are to be mutually
perpendicular and what you saw there is
sketch pad figuring out how to do that
now you notice this is the first system
ever to have a window and in fact the
simulated paper that he's drawing on is
about 1/3 of a mile on a side I believe
again a couple of lines drawn in quickly
and then giving the constraints to make
them be perpendicular to the lines that
they're terminated on and now the
constraint is collinearity so he's using
these two lines he drew two as
guidelines for these dashes
and now he will tell the guidelines to
be invisible so now he's drawing a hole
in this flange I think this is where the
damage shows up yeah so now he wants to
do a rivet he'll clear up in a second
sorry or maybe it won't so he's using
the center of the cross bars there as
the center of the circle again he's
saying let's make these guys mutually
perpendicular well that changes the
cross bars and that changes the circle
so you got a nice symmetric rivet in
fact sketchpad could solve some very
interesting nonlinear problems that
bridge that you saw on the slide you
could draw bridges in give the rules for
stresses and strain of beams and it
would calculate how much stress and
strain there would be forgiven weights
hung from the bridge you could draw an
electric circuit elements put in Ohm's
law and so forth
so now what he's gonna do is make some
rivets for his drawing here so the way
the controls here he's using one hand
with the light pen and on the other hand
he has some switches for commands for
different constraints and he also has
some knobs that he's turning they can
see this system led to an interest in
better displays it's actually not even a
line drawing display it's putting up
each dot individually and in fact the
there's a kind of a twinkling pattern
there's put up there so he says oh I
forgot there's these cross bars on the
rivet so I'll go to the master drawing
and I'll get rid of those guys and lo
and behold we see that the the these
rivets here were actually instances so
sketchpad was really the world's first
object-oriented system and he really had
pretty much of all the paraphernalia of
object-oriented programming and now he's
made a flange with the rivet in it and
he can use anything that he makes as a
master so now he's making instances of
the flange or the rivet and positioning
them and scaling them and so forth so
once asked Ivan how could you possibly
okay stop the tape that's enough
so I once they asked Ivan how could you
possibly have invented computer graphics
the world's first object-oriented
software system and as you can see one
of the very first dynamic problem
solvers that could do both linear and
nonlinear problems and Ivan said well I
didn't know it was hard and in fact if
you read his thesis but Bob do you know
did it ever get published out in the in
the world no it's this is besides still
being great today I mean it's really
saying something to be able to to read
something that is interesting today
so as you can actually learn something
from it by reading it today and
comparing with what's going on what is
really interesting is the diffident and
even apologetic tone in sketchpad
because it didn't do more so eivin's and
this is I think it's true of most of the
people that I think it was the great
people in the 60s is that they really
wanted it all so the image of what
sketchpad should do went far beyond what
it was able to do although when we look
at it today we were just awestruck by
what he was willing to take on just from
scratch and what he was able to
accomplish well right after that I found
my desk and they had a tradition at Utah
that the latest graduate student got the
latest dirty tasks and actually I was a
graduate student number seven so there
are actually quite a few dirty tasks
left for people to do and there's a pile
of listings and tapes on the desk that
was supposed to be the alcohol for the
campus computer that turned out to be
the first Simula system and the
documentation was quite incomprehensible
and finally another graduate student I
unrolled the listings for it down the
hall of Marilyn Janee hring building
some 80 feet long or so and he crawled
on it on one part of the listing and I
crawl imagine doing this on a display
today it was very useful that he could
crawl over it down there and I was
crawling over down here reading the
machine code try and figure out what the
what the thing did and we finally
realized that it was allocating storage
exactly the way sketchpad did in fact it
was kind of a programming language
version of the same kind of internal
model that sketchpad had and the the
good news was it was easier to do the
sketchpad couldn't solve every problem
you posed to it so it had a limited
range of things that could do but it did
those very elegantly Simula was a
generalized programming language and so
you could pretty much do anything that
you could write programs
but none of it was particularly elegant
and now in my in my checkered past was a
degree in molecular biology and this
book had come out in 1965 this visit to
Utah started in 66 or so and I'd read
this book by Watson and one of the neat
things he did in this book is this book
is still in print but in a current
edition first edition of this I think
was the first book that ever tried to do
an assay of living things so the
favorite animal that molecular biologist
looked at then was ecoli which is a
bacterium we have in our gut by the
millions helps us digest certain kinds
of food and by that time they were able
to tell us that about 70% of e.coli were
water and small/small charged molecules
which did not have which actually we're
of course important for the reactions
that were going on there but didn't
interact information li but there are
about 120 million organic components
that interact information Li and his
ends mostly enzymes proteins of various
kinds and DNA and so forth
and if you work out what these are in
terms of representing them on a computer
in a in a fairly compact way it's about
a hundred gigabytes of stuff going on
and so I wrote down there it's about
fifty thousand two megabyte desktops
worth in an e coli and one of the things
to think about here is how fast the
reactions are actually going on at the
temperature 37 degrees centigrade which
is what's pretty much what your body
temperature is inside of you these
medium-sized protein molecules those
little white things that look like
popcorn there
are able to move their own length in
about two nanoseconds it's a way of now
people when they take chemistry in high
school most chemistry teachers actually
don't understand why chemistry works and
they will shy away from any questions
from students asking just how can
molecules
how can atoms and molecules find each
other in order to have these reactions
and the answer is is that the thermal
agitation at that level of scale is
unbelievably violent I'll give you an
example if if a carbon atom is about the
size of a tennis ball then one of these
protein molecules is about the size of a
Volkswagen so an R scale if you can
imagine a Volkswagen made out of tennis
balls moving from here its own length in
two nanoseconds and if you multiply that
out you'll see that that is a scale
speed that's faster than the speed of
light so if we were actually transported
down in size to being able to look at
what an e.coli is doing at normal body
temperature we would be stunned by the
violence fact we could not see anything
that's going on it's just unbelievably
violent and that is why biology and
chemistry actually works something is
very hard to get into people's intuition
well so that is a very complex and
interesting structure and it happens to
be one five hundredth the size of a
typical cell in our body and we happen
to have between ten trillion and a
hundred trillion of these cells in our
body and yet 50 cell divisions are all
it takes to grow a baby now think of the
think of taking something much much
simpler like a 747 that Lee Sproul was
she was talking about a 777 and imagine
what you have to do to make it six
inches longer write the manuals for are
bigger than the plane they were listed
out I'm sure they're on CD ROMs now and
yet a baby gets six inches longer about
ten times in its life and you never have
to take it down for maintenance
so what we have here is something that
is a kind of informational machinery
that is just in a different league than
computers are even today and certainly
if you look at the number of components
in animal cells and think of how many we
have the other thing about them is that
they're dying all the time and not only
that they're actually exchanging their
structure so another interesting thing
that I knew from molecular biology is
that no atom in our body stays in our
body for more than seven years and in
fact more than 90% of the atoms in our
body are recycled every two weeks so if
you think about this is really quite
startling if you think of yourself is
actually a pattern moving through time
and space sucking up energy and material
and reformulating it to be yourself and
yet every seven years you have not a
single atom not even in your bones that
you had seven years before so this is a
completely different way of thinking
about things and things are going wrong
all the time but in structures like this
more things are going right well
something about Simula got me thinking
about computing that the reason I
suddenly realized that computers were
tiny tiny tiny little simple things they
were not the big physically they were
big but compared to biology there were
nothing hardly anything was going on and
the only reason programming worked on
them was because people were hardly
doing anything and what came to my mind
it was kind of like making a dog house
which unless you make it out of
toothpicks she can make a dog house out
of almost anything because the structure
is so simple compared to the strength of
the materials it's only when you go to
big things that you have to really
introduce architectures to make them
work and I suddenly it suddenly leptin
to my mind that the all of the
programming that I
known how to do in the 60s was nothing
even though it seemed hard to do but
compared to what the actual potential
for building structures was we were
going to have to shift to a different
way of doing it so I had had one of my
arthur kessler bingos the bingo was that
the computers are not like the clocks
they seemed to be where the clock if
anything goes wrong it stops and the
clock is something you fix and a clock
is something you build but in a
biological organism you don't fix them
you negotiate with them and you don't
build them you grow them and so this
notion of why shouldn't we be building
everything on the computer out of
self-healing intercommunicating parts
the way biology yeah and so the the this
was very compelling to me because of
course one of the reasons why cells are
a good idea is that nature is very very
messy about doing biochemistry and
requires there's enormous numbers of for
anybody who's discovered it you might
know that there are hundreds of
reactions just to move electrons around
and the reason is that the energy
margins are so small and that there was
no grand designer figuring out how to
move these electrons along nature found
out how gradually the biochemistry is
very kludgy and it requires stable
conditions so what the cell did was
allow this clue jury to continue in a
protected way his nature rarely undoes
things it basically adds on more kinds
of things and this is a way of taking
messy things that sort of worked and
guaranteeing that they had worked better
and then eventually of course they these
cells found out how to work together and
now looking back again at Simula what
similar was was almost one of these
things and they had been thinking about
simulating oil refineries and the thing
that I got out of it is
gee why not simulate programmatic things
let's get rid of data structures
entirely we'll simulate those we can
simulate servers on a network in fact
these kinds of systems are kind of like
servers on a network we can simulate
control structures we can simulate
physical objects we can simulate biology
in fact simulation again thinking about
what sketchpad was about is one of the
dominant metaphors that is in the
destiny of the of the computer and
there's one thing you can do with a
computer that biology doesn't do well
and that is you can share the DNA
biology does it by copying the DNA and
so when you want to replace something it
is really a complex operation people are
discovering how to do that now for
cystic fibrosis in the computer you can
actually share the DNA by extracting it
and having all the cell's look to a
master copy so this is very powerful
because it gives you meta control over
what the system actually is is all about
so that was my first revelation came in
the end of 66 and a little bit later
Dave Evans got me a consulting job with
guy by the name of Edie Cheadle who
wanted to build a little computer for
engineers and eventually we wound up
building a of it called the Flex machine
this is what looked at picture of it on
its own display and while we're just
starting and we knew that it wasn't the
first personal computer because West
Clark and Charlie Molnar had already
done one called the link at Lincoln labs
in the early 60s we hadn't thought about
this machine until Eadie Cheadle wanted
to do one and then we realized that
somebody had already done it and we were
able to learn quite a bit what you might
try and do on such a small machine this
machine by the way was made in some
quantity and a lot of fundamental
inventions were we're done on it like
the things that look like deck tapes
there but deck tapes are actually
invented for this machine by by Wes
Clark
and here's a shadowy figure now this
this actually isn't a picture of Bob
Barton because as far as I know his
pictures have never shown up on
photographs he's good he was he was
called the ghost who walks because he
was seen outside of Marilyn Janee hring
building and he was seen inside of
Marilyn earing building but he was never
seen entering or leaving suddenly he
would be there and then just as suddenly
he would not be there he was the guy who
designed the Burroughs be 5000 and I
think as the the greatest computer
designer who has ever lived and his his
influence in his own inimitable way had
a lot to do with how this little machine
of Cheadle's in mind executed we made it
execute directly one of the earliest
object-oriented languages and you see
one of his famous sayings up there
system's programmers or highest priests
civil occult so his his idea was if you
have to have an operating system then
you might be designing wrong and we
realized that if you had an
object-oriented system that you really
didn't have to have an operating system
because it actually would supply all of
the things you normally associate with
an operating system all by itself and so
as I said sketchpad had the first
windows and the the first multiple
window system I know of was sketch pad 3
that was done by Timothy Johnson showed
you different views of a
three-dimensional object and so we want
to do we need to have a windowing system
this is done at the same time as Ivan
Sutherland and Bob Sproul at at Harvard
we came up with a clipping divider idea
that was rather similar to I think Danny
Cohen's algorithm multiple views and so
forth now right as we were working on
this stuff we were visited by Doug
Engelbart and Doug I'm sure you remember
but when you traveled around back then
you used to travel with
you didn't travel like he used to travel
with a 16mm this is before video and
stuff so you travel with a 16 millimeter
projector and a film and the reason he
travel with his own projector he'd had
it modified so he could do stop frame
and the reason he did that is that
people who are not used to look looking
at cursors a lot of what he wanted
people to see was what people did with
the cursors on the screen as I recall a
movie on that one was a green display
because I think what you showed back
then was the 3100 or the control data
single user version of NLS because my
memory has it being in color and it was
green so I think it was that system that
was shown so this was this is the visit
that actually changed our our life
certainly changed my life because what
what angle Bart brought was not just a
vision of interacting with the system
but he had a philosophical underpinning
and that philosophical underpinning is
as important today maybe more important
today even than it was then one of the
phrases that he used that I particularly
liked and I'm not sure I still
understand it but on the other hand when
you're listening to this stuff its total
understanding is not necessary but his
phrase was thought vectors and concept
space and what he meant I think was that
what you're doing is creating an
extension of the kinds of spaces that
you think about think in terms of inside
of your head so is actually you're
creating an augmentation of the ways of
thinking in the ways of representing and
the ways of associating that was now
going to be extended in a way somewhat
analogous to the way writing is extended
us but something more like the way we
actually think and that what we're
really interested in is in particularly
the collisions of different kinds of
ideas so if you think of Kessler's
diagram there you can see that one of
the things that you would like
for maximum creativity and getting out
of your rut is to constantly have the
system help you see different sides to
things to remind you that you're in a
context and that there are other
contexts and but anyway such was the his
talk was so so fantastic that like all
really good talks I think everybody came
away from that realizing that this was
going this was an actual turning point
in the history of design for computer
science I think all of us were very
interested in trying to trying to do
something with that I'm not going to
show you the movie because you saw it
saw yesterday of the 1968 demonstration
in San Francisco those of us who are
there I was sick as a dog but I went
anyway I had strep throat and maybe
pneumonia but I wasn't going to miss it
for the world and it's still six in my
mind is one of the greatest expositions
of a new set of ideas that I've ever
seen I think everybody who was there
remembers and there are a lot of people
there there must have been somewhere
between two and three thousand people
witnessing that actually I I remember
that was where I met Andy Van Dam and
for those of you who only known Andy in
the last 20 years or so
I want to reveal to you that in 1968
Andy was a hippie he had long hair and
at the very least a goatee if not more
and he was a wonderful angry young man
at that point I remember him being both
tremendously impressed with the
Engelbart system and amazed that it
actually did what it did
that was my my impression of Andy back
then right around this time I visited
Ivan Sutherland at Harvard and met Bob
sprout Bob's prowl then was a I was an
undergraduate who was simultaneously
graduating from Harvard I believe editor
of the yearbook and but he spent almost
24 hours a day
helping to wire up the clipping divider
for this first head mounted display
machine and I understand that he slowed
down quite a bit he only works 20 hours
a day now instead of instead of 23 and a
half now just one little plug here for
why all this stuff worked I think these
are the most enlightened funders that we
know of in this half century and I
haven't heard lick lighters name
mentioned too much today Allah Li Li
mentioned it a lot of this was because
of his understanding personality and
vision and the succession of the ARPA
funders during this golden age before it
became DARPA where Licklider Ivan
Sutherland when he was only 26 Taylor
who later went on to be the founder of
the computer stuff at Xerox PARC and and
Larry Roberts so this and their basic
idea was to fund people instead of
projects one of the great ideas of all
time and fun directions instead of goals
I don't think anybody else would have
fun funded Engelbart in those days
because I believe he must have appeared
to most people in fact I know he
appeared to most people as somebody who
was completely deranged and out of his
mind and it's real it's a real pity that
the ARPA funding from the 60s didn't
carry over into the 70s or I think
history would have been quite different
today because sometimes the people who
can see the forest and see see the
deepest are the ones that are most
difficult for the the bean counters due
to understand so I meant Marvin back
then
Marvin gave it's a typical Marvin
comment like to say you don't understand
anything if you only understand it one
way and he gave a talk on education and
mentioned some of the stuff he'd been
doing was Seymour Papert
and the talk was so interesting I read
his book my other major was a math
Maddox so I found in this book besides a
lot of finite automata stuff some really
interesting ways of thinking about
universal computing not just touring
machines but Marvin did a very funny
thing of when he was explaining girdle
numbers and how GERD L made a kind of a
list structure out of exponents of
factorizations of integers Marvin built
an entire Lisp system in one of the
chapters in this book using that as the
representation it was a really weird way
of learning less but it got me got me
interested in this way of thinking about
things and let's show the next next
little film then I went to RAND
Corporation this is still in 68 and I
saw this system yep go ahead and run it
it's got sound first we erase a flow
arrow then move the connector out of the
way so that we may draw a box in its
place cz wants a box and makes one's
forum now it's recognizing as printing
the printing in the box is being used as
commentary only in this case the box is
slightly too large so we may change its
size that's where modern-day window
control came from literally then dry
flow from the connector to the box
attach a decision element to the box and
joy flow from it to scan we then erased
the floor arrows attached to the process
post new area and move the box to a new
position
this allows us to draw a new box okay
now you may have seen character
recognition done worse on some products
today partly because it's as Roger was
saying is that they weren't trying to do
the 80/20 this was an 80/20 thing where
it did what it did
essentially perfectly almost perfectly
you had to learn a little bit it did
what it did what it did and there are a
bunch of things that it that it wouldn't
do and but the result of it was that the
character recognition part on this
particular interface which the system is
called the Grail system the character
recognition was almost foolproof and
very very transparent in the user
interface and there were some further
advances done at Harvard and elsewhere
on doing this and this this really
struck me as a very I thought it was a
kind of an intimate way of interacting
with with the computer and then just a
little bit after that a couple of weeks
after that I visited Seymour Papert for
the first time out here in Lexington and
saw his work with children and that was
another one see for me the 60s was
pretty much a continual series of holy
Sh it's just one after the other it was
almost over and I think I think it's you
know part of it is the golden nostalgia
I'm sure from old farts but also I think
actually this stuff is is still pretty
neat even today I think the Grail system
was neat I think sketchpad was neat I
think NLS was really neat it was really
a joy to learn NLS and have a sense of
what it could mean to be a virtuoso in
dealing with your external
representations so Peppard had another
profound idea and that was that whatever
the computer was it wasn't really a tool
or even a vehicle in the sense of being
an automobile
compared to ibm's railroads but papper
thought of it as being a medium for
powerful idea now Nicholas was hedging
on the definition of a medium I like
Neil postman's definition Neil postman
says technology is a machinery like the
printing press is a machine the computer
is a machine and he says media are the
purposes to which we put that machinery
so for him the media on the printing
press or things like Bibles indulgences
money
comic books romance novels pornography
political essays scientific essays so as
a wide range of media that is all
printed all represented all brought
forth by the same piece of technology so
if you think of media as purposeful aims
you see the strongest things that Ivan
Sutherland and Doug Engelbart and some
of these other people did we're actually
creating media and I didn't realize that
until I saw Seymour working with the
kids he realized that there was there's
only one way of thinking about this to
me and that was it was a kind of it was
a kind of medium being brought forth
from machinery and it was going to be
very much like the printing press so
flying back to Utah I sketched this
thing which I laid it made a cardboard
model of which later became called the
Dynabook and it was hollow filled it up
with lead pellets to see how heavy you
could make it before people didn't want
to carry it anymore and the result was
about two pounds so we had this notion
that if you're going to have an intimate
medium then it would have to you'd have
to do mundane things casual things on it
so we asked the question what would it
be like to take a grocery list and
actually put it on a computer and
actually carry it into the grocery store
and be willing to carry it out with two
bags of groceries what kind of computer
would that have to be okay and one of
things that was happening in the end of
the 60s was that ARPA had been doing the
ARPANET
but Larry Roberts and some of the other
people who were Bob Kahn and other
people who were driving the ARPANET
we're also thinking of packet radio back
then so in 69 I remember driving around
I think it was a Ford van with the model
33 teletype in the back and all kinds of
radio equipment communicating with I
think it was actually angle Bart's
computer at SR I buy radio at 10
characters a second on this model 33
teletype so there's a whole sense that
that computing was going to get to be
mobile and I think many of you may know
that Larry Roberts last set of things
that he was interested in doing were to
have a handheld radio terminal that
would be portable and would connect you
through packet radio to the ARPANET so
the other thing is I actually tried to
get the picture here but Lee I'm sorry
we actually did we actually were
thinking of this thing being networked
because I think networking was part of
the ARPA dream and the first cartoon I
ever did of this machine I'll show you
later shows two kids playing space war
with each other each on their own
Dynabook communicating by by radio so
one of the just having these ideas here
led to something kind of interesting and
that is it struck me that having a time
sharing graphics terminal this desktop
computer that Cheadle and I have been
working on in this cardboard model
reminded me of something that had
already happened hundreds of years
before and that was the development of
of printing so on the far left is a
manuscript book chained to its little
desk if you ever been in a medieval
library they have one still in Florence
they're like the size of this room or
maybe twice the size of this room but
they only have about 70 or 80 books the
one of the largest libraries in Europe
in 1400 was the Vatican Library it had
372 books
the richest man in France who was the
brother of the King was a bibliophile
and had books made for him he had 154
when he died in 1435 so these books cost
the equivalent of millions of dollars
and they were so rare that only
institutions could afford them in 1454
at the Nurenberg Book Fair Gutenberg
showed 20 Bibles and people marveled at
two things one is how alike the Bibles
were to each other that was a really new
you could look at one page and it looked
just like the same page on another Bible
they'd never seen that before and the
other thing was that the cost had come
way down these Bibles only costs three
years of a clerks wages maybe $60,000
today and so you could think of those as
being workstations kind of things that
institutions smaller institutions and
towns and some individuals could own and
you notice that the Gutenberg Bible was
illuminated because they made every
effort to make it look like the
manuscript books on the left and then 50
years later to me is when printing
actually happened and you have books
that instead of being this size are now
this size these are printed by Aldous
who's whose last name was not pagemaker
his name was Aldus Manutius but he's the
person that the eldest corporation took
their name from and he was a venetian
printer who had been a scholar and he
went out and decided books should be
this size because he went out and
measured saddlebags and Venice because
the first offering from his printing
press in 1495 was called the portable
library and instead of printing just one
book one kind of book the Bible
Aldus over the next thirty five years
printed 40,000 different titles he and
his sons went around and gathered up all
of the writing that the Greeks and the
Romans had done that they could find
they printed each one of them and many
of the fonts that we have today were
invented by Aldous in order to make this
stuff more readable Aldous is also the
inventor of something quite unusual and
that is page numbers page numbers went
in two books the first time ever 65
years after the invention of the
printing press so they went in in 1516
and we know why they did not go in there
for sequencing because the way
sequencing was done was to print the
next word on the next page down in the
last line so you could see how the pages
went together did not go in there in
order to refer to other books because
there were no really standard editions
of books each press run was two to four
to five thousand copies page numbers
went in there partly at the instigation
of Erasmus and they went in there
because they were just starting to write
down arguments that were so complicated
that they wanted to refer people back to
what they had said previously so the
first page numbering systems were done
in order to if you will hyperlink a
piece of text within itself so as you're
following along an argument sequentially
the author could say and as I said back
on page 162 blah blah and you could go
back there and check it out so page
numbers came in as people started
realizing that the reproducibility
of the books allowed for much more
complicated arguments to put in there
and not be garbled by somebody who is
trying to copy the book by hand and this
led in turn to this idea of trying to
link the arguments closer together
there's a very interesting sidelight and
given that it took 65 years to happen
from the invention of the printing press
I also use it as a kind of a metaphor
for what we haven't thought of yet
right because clearly we are somewhere
between the desktop computer and this
Dynabook kind of machine and it's
sobering to realize that nothing in the
history of printing counted in those 50
years there was a complete transitional
stage where almost everybody was looking
backwards and if we look at the way most
people use computers today it's really
pathetic because most people do not do
hyperlinking most people do not use
computers the way Engelbart thought they
should be used and most people do not
use computers the way Ivan Sutherlands
thought they should be used what most
people are doing is imitating paper
either in prose or imitating paper in
terms of accounting and that echoes all
the way back to Sumerian times because
as far as anybody can tell the invention
of writing itself came about first to
account for the Kings wine jars and then
a few hundred years after that they
realized they could also write down some
of their some of their poetry so what's
been going on in computing has been very
very much as McLuhan once said we're
driving faster and faster into the
future but steering only by looking
through the rearview mirror I think
that's been going on and when we can we
can think of a corner being turned into
the actual modern era I just gave a talk
in Korea whose title was the computer
revolution hasn't happened yet
and I would say that it hasn't happened
yet until people start using the
computer for dealing with thought
vectors in concept space and dealing
with the idea that you can have active
dynamic models of the things you're
trying to represent
so that led to a kind of a sense that
there were three different religions and
we didn't know very much about what the
righthand religion was going to be but
we could see that there was certainly a
mainframe religion in which Tom Watson
jr. was the Pope that there were was
going to be a desktop revolution and
religion because Moore's law said that
was going to happen and then we had this
more mythical notion of pervasively
networked systems with computers that
were kind of like clothing it's one of
the last characters I'm going to mention
here is Butler Lampson who talked to
even faster
back in the 60s than he does today and
he once came to a actually a meeting on
the ARPANET standards and gave a talk on
capability operating systems in which he
had been working on one at Berkeley and
what had happened as the meeting went
later and later and later and finally
Butler said well I have a plane I have
to catch and they said when do you have
to leave he says I have to leave in
about 15 minutes and they said well
would you like to wait until next time
to give your talking says oh no I'll
give my talk right now and he got up and
gave in an hour talk in 15 minutes on
capability operating systems and it was
one of the clearest talks I've ever
heard and part of the idea here is
something that is part and parcel of
objects which is but in in this kind of
operating system you think of clients
and services the services tend to be
generic like printing and searching and
updating and viewing and delegating and
the clients are different kinds of
objects the objects in this sense are
usually large things they're like the
size of UNIX processes but they have
certain things that they can do that are
as generic as possible there are a
variety of these kinds of things and
then
each one of these clients of the
services has a different set of
privileges and the way it's usually
implemented is by adding a little bit
map to a protected pointer that says
which of these privileges you have
access to so this is a very compelling
way of thinking about and when I in my
mind what I was thinking about was gee
everything should be an object and so
the question is how could you implement
this kind of protection which seemed
very very useful and necessary even for
ordinary programming how could you do it
in a frying fine-grain way and that
leads to this notion of designing in
terms of concepts that you think of
behavioral concepts and transmitted into
object-oriented terms you think of
having different kinds of things
different classes of things different
types of things but you're trying to
design everything in terms of these
generic concepts and what you wind up
with is something that if you can limit
the number of concepts that you're
dealing with then your design tasks
become much much easier and finally we
had all of again we were only I was only
thinking about the middle panel here as
opposed to the one on the far left we
realized that the the ARPANET would
actually need objects for sure because
networking particularly pervasive
networking means heterogeneity when you
have heterogeneity you better not
require people to have to parse things
in order to understand them you really
want to be able to execute them in order
to understand them so that they have
their own understanding with it with
them and we felt that something like
objects should actually be adapted for
the ARPANET that was a little bit too
early that was brought up in one of the
meetings back there and it was felt to
be a little bit too early but I think we
can see from the state of the internet
today that this is absolutely critical
to get out of a data structure oriented
way of doing things which is kind of
like going back to ms-dos and trying to
get to as
situation where the objects that we
interact with don't have to be from the
same object-oriented language don't have
to have been created on the same kind of
machine but nonetheless can interact and
interoperate with each other and then
finally towards the end of the 60s I
finally went through this half page of
code in the Lisp 1.5 programmers manual
and realized that McCarthy had actually
come up with an incredible way of
thinking about what programming should
be and he was doing it to prove a
different kind of point and as he as he
says himself it wasn't his fault that
Steve Russell sat down and made it work
but once it did get going
it provided a completely different way
of thinking about what it means to
implement programming languages and I
started thinking very seriously about
what an OOP language would be like if it
were set up like Lisp I think of this as
the Maxwell's equations for computers
because everything you can do with a
computer and in a high-level form is
there on that half page so it's a very
very interesting thing to spend in a
Sunday afternoon going through and I
think everybody who has gone through
this and and understood it spent those
couple of hours to go through it
remembers that time when they suddenly
said oh wait a minute
now it wasn't helped by the fact that
this particular rendition in this book
has a bug in it it has one bug and that
bug can cause as an extra couple of
hours to be taken until you're quite
sure that you understand all of it and
that there really is a bug it turns out
there is and what is the bug well of
course they left out one set of
parentheses
then the last part of the 60s was
realizing this again I want to say
something about Doug Engelbart and nls
the other part of his project that was
so impressive to me as a graduate
student was when you visited the
augmentation Research Center at SR I
what you found was kind of the epitome
of what a research project should be
like they had lofty goals
lots of committed people they're willing
to do any amount of building their own
hardware and software which they did
they built their own display system and
they built their own IO devices and they
built most of their software and they
helped modify the operating system in
order to make all of this stuff work and
actually the other thing I should have
mentioned I think everybody noticed
yesterday that
NLS was kind of zippy as far as response
would you like to have your desktop
computer be as responsive as that system
was instead of lumbering around trying
to bring stuff up well I realized that
in order for to do a computer for kids
that what we had to do was to build a
bunch of them and this is one of the
entries in my notebook back then of what
I wanted to build and at that point
Drock spark came along and we got a
chance to try some of these ideas out
now to me the moral of some of this
looking back in the past is that it is
incredible how powerful a new context is
and it's also incredible how stultifying
it is after a couple of years I didn't
realize until looking back on this but I
think all of us have had this feeling
that the very things that made our ideas
work when we're in a context we're also
the ones that held us up from thinking
about other ideas so these contexts
we're out but we can only think about
things in terms of context when we go to
one context to another we get life for a
few years but then there's a syndrome
which I call the sub-goals becoming the
goals that sets in usually the
sub-goals are hard enough to require a
couple of years work and once you've
been working on them for a couple of
years they become the goals of the
project and all of a sudden it's hard to
remember why you started the project in
the first place so I think one of the
hardest things to do on these
large-scale things that require so many
different things to be done over so many
years is to constantly be able to renew
what the actual dream was and it takes
so long to get people to understand what
these ideas are this is one of my
favorite slides because it shows hand
axes from to prehistoric periods the one
on the left you might notice that when
you chop with it it chops you because
the place where you grabbed it on the
bottom there is pretty sharp it's almost
as sharp as the top and then a little
bit later somebody came up with a hand
axe that was blunter on the bottom so it
wouldn't chop you as much and according
to archeologists the period of time
between these two was about two hundred
thousand years so you can imagine every
generation probably somebody sitting
around a campfire chopping with one of
these things on the left said geez this
is hurting yeah I just I'll just chip
this away and probably got burned at the
stake for going against their traditions
of the tribe which are probably
something puritanical like work is good
for you and it sure it hurts but and so
forth then finally probably by an
accident some chieftain of some tribe
came up with the blender and won and
made it a rule that everybody should
have blend to end ones and that's how
this change happened so there's this low
pass filter to reality and the biggest
example of it is what's happened to
personal computing since 1980 the
low-pass filter has been so dominant
that all we get is about a 60 cycle hum
for most of these ideas from the 60s
look at what most people are doing with
personal computers they have
unbelievable resources angle Bart's SDS
940 had 192k
and it ran 20 users as a time sharing
system with 192k we've got megabytes the
system is much less responsive that it
is the user interface is worse than it
was and humankind has sat down for one
of these 20 years slumbers right now
bedazzled by stuff that isn't very good
so last slide is a metaphor for this
whole talk and that is something that
was actually found out about frogs at
MIT here and that is that frogs don't
know what their food looks like so if
you take their normal food which your
flies paralyze them with a little
chloroform and put the Flies out in
front of the frog the frog will not eat
them the Frog will just starve to death
but if you flip a piece of cardboard at
the flog it will try and eat it every
time because what it thinks food is is
an oblong thing that is moving and I
think this is a good metaphor for a
scientist because the way I think of the
Flies is that their ideas the ideas are
in front of us all of the time and we
just can't see them what we have to do
is periodically find a way of realizing
that you can't see unless you admit
you're blind and every time we admit
we're blind we can actually see a bit
and then we can push on to the next
stage of this grand adventure thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks a lot Alan we'll take a few
questions directed to Alan specifically
and then we're going to arrange for the
panel okay you just want to go back to
one of the earliest slides of the
doghouse that I think actually the
doghouse is the better model than the
bridge because if we look at the scale
the bridge is about a middle-sized
construction grab the tiny compared to
cities and societies which are totally
unaffected
yet somehow work we don't the thing is
we don't quite understand how they work
and I think that's really a challenge
bring to me go by you're making my point
that's the whole the whole point about
biology is that it works in the face of
error and not having to be strictly
architected okay because like I said dog
houses work simply because they're so
simple compared to the strength of
material so that's a different point
than the but the the very point I was
trying to make about when you go up into
real complexity you have to find a way
of getting things to work together even
when they don't want to terribly so the
Constitution of the u.s. is a pretty
interesting meta program so the nice
thing is it's small it's it's very very
small and it's not a set of laws it's a
set of principles for dealing with
millions of only semi cooperative
components namely us other questions yes
not so much a question but a comment it
seems to me that you know you focused on
the 60s and it's probably natural to
think of the Golden Age in in the area
where you get your own awakening and you
start to become productive in a creative
part of society but for everybody who's
in the field their golden age is
probably going to be some other decade
or whatever as I went back and just sort
of picked another one like the 70s and
just sort of made the list of things
that came out there this is the hero
when ARPA had addy in front of it I was
thinking of Minsky's adage about not
being right about something for too long
it made the list of the things that came
out of that decade and it seems to me
they were pretty impressive the first
work on speech understanding in a
systematic way started in that decade
with Alan Newell push the work on image
understanding started in that decade the
work the internet came out of that
decade the microprocessor was in the
decade of the 70s the personal computer
really came out of the decade of the 70s
the work on lands radio networks and
VLSI design the thing that got empowered
the universities came out of the 70s and
probably an awful lot of the
object-oriented programming work came
out of the 70s as well although you
would probably know I think it seems to
me it's a little unfair to cite the 60s
as the golden age relative to all of
their ages because I think it's relative
to our own contexts well I hope I wasn't
doing that because of course the most
productive period in my life was in the
seventies not in the in the 60s the
reason I picked the 60s was that was
when I think a lot of these ideas
manifested itself in such a way that we
could see that they were possible and a
lot of the shoes were dropped in the 70s
but I certainly I think of the seventies
much more as engineering Fitch's most of
the stuff we did at Xerox PARC was kind
of a second engineering pass on things
we'd failed at you know because the
things were bubblegum together we didn't
completely
understand so for instance one of the
dicta that Butler Lampson got us to
agree to in the early days of Xerox PARC
is we should never do something that
isn't engineered for 100 users and that
made us much more conservative than we
had been in the 60s but it also added
much more reality to the things that we
did and of course a lot of the success
that we had was because we could make a
hundred of something or make a machine
that you could run a hundred people on
or make sauce offer that you can move
around but I to me that was very
different than the I think of it as
being less creative and more engineering
than the than the 60s but as you say
other people might just depends on when
you when you start from my standpoint I
don't think that you know it's silly to
try and compare one person's gods with
another but I think that to me Ivan
Sutherland and Doug Engelbart did the
most towering important stuff in the
last 35 years and I think that stands up
pretty well today yes somebody else was
okay great
[Applause]
before we go into the panel I want to do
a couple of things first of all Paul
Penfield has to leave for a memorial
service and I'd like to thank him on our
joint behalf for a job very well done he
and a lot of people at MIT like Ed over
there and Scott and lots and lots of
other people put in real quality time
making this happen so thank you very
much Paul and the rest of you
[Applause]
the second thing I have to tell you is
Paul has a announcement I just want to
thank everyone for coming to this has
been a real wonderful opportunity for me
to see some aspects of this community
that I hadn't been as filming heroes as
I should and I want to personally thank
Andy for putting this together and he
says that we did yeoman job but I can
assure you but Andy in setting this up
over the past several months has put in
far more effort but anyone at MIT has
and I think the whole group deserves to
thank Andy for organizing
thank you very much as you know it was
the three guys from EBT who really
thought of it and Lisa who executed it
but I got to invite the speakers that
was the best part
speaking about speakers you all know
what day it is today
Friday the 13th now I'm not normally a
superstitious person however I have to
find some explanation for what happened
here's what happened inadvertently tech
nelson's tape got recorded over so we do
not have an official record of his great
speech here I just found out about this
a little time ago this is not a joke I'm
sorry I wish it were and we are trying
to find people who may have recorded it
there are a couple of possibilities
there may be some folks out over the
mbone who recorded it it's a classic
point of failure and despite all of the
duplication that we had in equipment and
people something went wrong in any case
we asked Ted what he would like to do
about it he was a gentleman to the core
and took it exceedingly well I think I
would have gone straight through the
ceiling fortunately he's jet lagged and
so he didn't react quite as strongly as
he might have as I said and he handled
it beautifully
we thought the folks here at MIT thought
that what might be fun and interesting
is to let them have the last word as it
were a reprise performance and any of
you are welcome to stay while Ted tries
to lay down another track for the
historical record and we'll do that
after the panel some of you have to go
some of you have other things to do some
of you whatever you're all more than
welcome to sit in on this as Ted tries
his best to recapture the moment we
apologize
we'll do another moment of course so
that's where we are we're gonna take a
couple of minutes to set up the chairs
for the panel's panel and then we carry
on well why don't we just get started
and you can fire at will at the people
who are here
fire when ready we started this
discussion by looking at Bush's vision
of Memex and we just heard Alan talk
about the Golden Age of the 60s and here
we are 1994 and we've ended up with
Windows which is kind of a bleak thought
so I'd ask any of you who are interested
to postulate where we would be if
Windows never existed would we have had
to invent it or would we be someplace
different and where would we be I'm
sorry clarification is the question
Microsoft Windows or Windows in general
we will be missing nothing Microsoft
doesn't even claim that they're a highly
innovative company they take programs
that have already existed and sold well
from other vendors such as Lotus and
WordPerfect
and they do a commercially better job
rewriting these programs and selling
them as Excel and WordPerfect so
wouldn't be missing any important
technology
as far as I can see well I don't I think
would mean at park so I didn't talk
about the park phase of the thing but
that Park one of the one of the goals
was to do NL s as a distributed system
and all of the Altos there had the five
finger keyboards as well as the the
mouse on them and the you know we we had
done a few I mean we basically love to
NL s and we've done a few modifications
which we thought even sped up in NL s
part of the interaction scheme on it was
because the I believe was because the
the analog mouse there was some drift in
it so one of the things that they did
was to say what kind of a thing you were
pointing at so you'd say move character
and move word or move paragraph so forth
it was kind of a procedural where you
gave the command first and then you
would go bug bug and then command accept
and we realized at Xerox PARC that this
was that you wanted to have a speedy
scheme for interacting and we thought we
could go even one better by selecting
the object so you'd select the thing
that you're going to do something to you
would give the command and then in the
case of move character you'd go select
move select and that would do it with
fewer keystrokes now the the abortion
that happened outs after Park was the
misunderstanding of the user interface
that we did for children which was the
overlapping window interface which we
made as naive as absolutely possibly
good to the point of not having any
workflow ideas in it and that was taken
over uncritically out into the outside
world so we have many systems like Lotus
Notes and many mail systems that when
you say reply it comes up with a window
over the very thing you were reading as
though there weren't any connection
between these things so this is an
abortion to me and but it's basically
part of the whole field whereas our
notion was that you start the kids off
on this fairly simple naive thing and
then there would be an actual
progression
where you would get up to this several
commands a second kind of thing that you
could do within LS if you ever seen
anybody use in LS it is really marvelous
because you're kind of flying along
through the stuff several commands a
second and there's this complete
different sense of what what it means to
interact then you have today and I think
all of that so III characterizes what we
have today is a as a wonderful bike with
training wheels on and nobody knows the
training wheels are on so nobody's
trying to take them off so maybe Doug
has a comment on that but that's so I
just feel like we're way way behind
where we where we could have been if it
weren't for the way commercialization
turned out well strangely enough I feel
the same yeah it's part part of the
thing of the easy to learn and natural
to use thing that became sort of a god
to follow and that the marketplace is
driving and it was successful and you
could mark it on that basis but it's the
some of the diagrams pictures I didn't
quite get to the other day was you know
how do you ever migrate from a tricycle
to a bicycle because a bicycle is very
unnatural and very hard to learn
compared to getting on a tricycle and
riding and you know it's it it in
society it has superseded all the
tricycles essentially for anybody over
five years old or something
so there's there's a lot in the whole
whole idea of high performance knowledge
work is yet to kind of come up and be in
the domain it's sort of you know you got
to make it easy and you know it's still
the orientation of automating what you
used to do instead of moving to a whole
new domain which obviously you're gonna
have to learn quite a few new skills and
so you make analogies of saying suppose
you wanted to move up on the ski slopes
and be mobile on skis you know well just
visiting them for an afternoon is not
going to you know you're not going to
find so people I'd love to have
photographs of skateboards and skis and
you know windsurfing and all of that to
show you what people can read
if they have a new way supplied by
technology to be mobile in a different
environment and none of that can be done
if people insisted that it was an
easy-to-learn thing
so it's anyway so moving your way around
those thought vectors the concept space
I'd forgotten I must have that so good
[Applause]
anyway that that's that's a nice
formulation what I've been saying but
you know it's to externalize your
thoughts in the concept structures that
are meaningful outside and moving around
flexibly and manipulating them and
viewing them it's it's a new way to
operate on a new kind of externalized
media to extract like that so to keep
doing it in the model of the old media
is just a hang-up that some place we're
going to break that you know that
perspective and shift and then then the
idea of high performance and the idea of
high performance teams who've learned to
coordinate to get that ball down the
field together in all kinds of
operations with very different
operations so I feel like the real
breakthrough for us getting someplace is
going to be when we say all right let's
put together high performance knowledge
work teams and let's pick the roles
they're going to play within our
organizations in some way and such that
even though they operate very
differently from their peers out in the
rest of the organization they can
interact with them and support them very
effectively so there are roles like that
that would be very effective and
everyone else can sort of see because
they're interacting these guys what they
can do and suppose it does take 200
hours of specialized training etc like
that
that's less than boot camp I feel like
that so anyway to me that's that's kind
of the only way the evolution of all
those boxes and that paradigm map about
deployment was really coming down and
showing you that special-purpose teams
is one kind of thing the way that they
can propagate and very different from
moving a group of people who have an
existing set of staff and processes and
methods and skills and equipment and
trying to move them all together it's
it's a it's a practically impossible
task to do that in any significantly
large step without having casualties in
there and you know that just aren't all
equipped to be mobile in that
face anyway so there's a lot to go with
that thing and all stems from looking at
today and saying you know why do we
accept that you know that that that's
the modern thing and it's almost like a
religion she's in any other company I'm
afraid to bring that out
but maybe I have to run from this one
too I hadn't heard you say this before
you're basically proposing some kind of
information SWAT team that can move
swiftly through an organization and or
or or or is going to be some elite
Einsatz copla in the in the in the files
is very exciting an interesting concept
but I but how would that how would that
function organizationally know that I
mentioned the other day that that if you
if you're gonna have a strategy to go
ahead with your organization's you just
can't lift them all at once so the
strategy I kind of finally worked out is
is that you you know to that in that
improvement infrastructure term I
mentioned I didn't show you much below
that but in that improvement
infrastructure there are roles in the
improvement process for high performance
teams they would really be helping the
information and the improvement process
go about and then their roles their
roles for them to be plugged into an
organization and to function that would
be very supportive and this is all
assuming that that's those are the
outposts that are going to start
everybody's going to start moving there
as well as you can but you just can't
lift the whole organization in some very
radical way and so that that's a part of
the process so yes they are an elite
team but you're assuming that in some
number of years you'll learn how to get
the whole organization there I think the
gruesome practical point is that when
you that finding a path of support
vectors through concept space to where
you are it may be one thing but the
transition path to get the world there
may be a very very different path
so you went so that you have to find a
a path of whatever they are pushing the
world vectors by where each step is
monotone where that each step is
downhill for the person who has to make
that step so now your original question
which says Microsoft's existence and the
dominance of DOS and later Windows
helped basically if if at some point
Microsoft has to make a change obviously
that's gonna be one of the more
difficult people took to put them in a
position so the next step it's downhill
and it can happen and one of the things
that can make that easier is if you have
as if instead of having just one
operating system you have two you might
ask for example what would have happen
if the Mac hadn't been there maybe we'd
still be using das without windows so
there's an argument which says this is
easier and I wouldn't say it's in a
situation where you don't have any
dominance you don't have any commonality
maybe that's what he'll of Unix
the people who are all developing things
on the UNIX in fact because they didn't
have enough commonality it was difficult
to make code that you could pass around
it's difficult to spread things around
so you don't the fact that you've got -
there at least means that if you're not
trying to change the operating system
you can roll out all kinds of software
very quickly so that's great a great
advantage the internet and Darce if you
with what you can do what you want with
the internet and dusts then you can do
it very quickly and roll it out that's
when you want to change the internet you
want to change dos that you've got
yourself a big problem and having so
when we the way I hope it will maybe
work for the web protocols and all the
web these web standards which we hope we
will be able to evolve from their clergy
current state into the to the beautiful
golden dream is there in any case where
you we use lay down a standard you also
allow there to be a second and you show
a path whereby if a third one comes up
which is better you can move in that
direction so you always have one on the
heels of the first keeping and keeping
it honest and you have a transition it
to be able to unhook it all together
later on American television is kind of
a counter example of in the effort to
make it really easy for everybody to
watch television I'm not sure I see any
path back upwards towards enlightenment
because the advertisers are quite happy
and so as Microsoft is quite happy with
the the stage of blindness that
everybody is in right now so I don't
think there's a it's a great idea
there's a there's a economic law called
Gresham's law which says the bad
that's easily produced drives out the
good because it resets the whole notion
of normality so I think it's personally
I think if somebody invented a bicycle
and it didn't exist today they couldn't
get anybody to buy it because it takes
more than five minutes to learn that is
really pathetic when you think about it
as far as television is concerned that
the operative phrase a few minutes ago
was a comfortable step down I'd say you
want to make your steps up comfortable
there there it's kind of take stress but
and you have to minimize it and you know
the older you get the harder it is to
change the I keep I keep getting that
thrown back in me and since you're gonna
ask all the old guys that are ready to
retire that they're supposed to shift
and change and but the only answer you
can really get is a look there's a lot
of potential for organizations to get a
lot more competent in their knowledge
work just a lot more and it's gonna take
a lot of change and the organizations
that learn how to do it are going to be
successful maybe the only ones that will
survive including mankind so look we've
got to get there so what you need to do
is say look we have to find a strategy
that's as smart as possible for
accommodating all the human and social
characteristics a change has to cope
with as well as the dynamics and expense
of changing etc so we we have to find a
strategy so that's that's the major push
in our bootstrapping thing is to say yes
you know it looks like a very smart
thing to do is to build an appropriate
improvement infrastructure and then as
rapidly as possible get the improvements
in these capabilities so they can plug
into the improvement in structure too so
that you're improving your improvement
process maybe even faster than the other
but that that just looked like the only
strategy I could think of and there's a
practical way to go after so strange as
it sounds that's what we're after
so anyway
next question okay I wanted to thank
Alan for his retrospective Oh I'm Mike
Saida Naval Postgraduate School right I
want to thank Alan for his retrospective
of the 60s and there was an important
slide in there that I think got kind of
muddied which talks about the Golden Age
of ARPA and I like that print on the
bottom which is fun people not projects
try and point out actually I I receive a
lot of ARPA money right now and ARPA
today is very different from 30 years
ago I've been on my own money for 22
years so I know this had an interesting
experience about in June July of last
fiscal of this year received a note from
my ARPA program manager saying we have a
new director of ARPA you need to take
your proposal that I've already sent you
the money for and provide a three and
forward a title for each task a task
number for each task a start date for
each task an end date for each task what
was where you over budget on budget or
what for each task and he was going the
director of ARPA was going to look at
the tasks and say which ones he was
going to fund for money that was already
there and so on when I saw your fun
people not projects and I'm saying fun
projects not tasks I kind of I'm a
little bit nervous about the way we're
going right now so this is not an attack
of art by ARPA's been extremely good to
me over the years or but it's just the
orientation of the balance the bottom
line is a little bit out of whack I
think so like here's some comments that
really isn't just in our part and out in
the industry too and it's it's like if
you can't explain it to me in five
minutes you know I don't think I should
even consider it somebody won't say to
you and you it says well you can't you
can't explain something very novel in
five minutes and they want the bottom
line and you can be you say I'm
convinced and the general thing there
couldn't be anything else you have to
get there but that isn't the kind of
thing that that sells and so it's sort
of them some kind of modern type way to
manage
but I think it's going to get our
country and our industry into real
trouble yeah I mean this this
presupposes I know what the system is
going to look like precisely at the end
when I'm handing in the proposal well
it's the kind of thing that can work
when you're making incremental
improvements and so that the guy that's
evaluating knows the system and knows
that yes if you get delivery that much
faster the customer and that's what your
bottom line is yeah I can see it okay
good but it really doesn't work if you
said I got a brand new material it'll
make your products very different and I
can't tell you how much different but
you gotta explore that you can't do that
kind of anyway yeah if I could respond
to that briefly um I guess I would start
by saying that one person's bug is
another person's feature often and that
there are different models of how the
system ought to work just as there are
different models of life depending on
what stage of evolution and involvement
in that you are arpa-e is sill I would
say not to try and defend any specific
action because I haven't been involved
with them for for quite a while still an
organization of people and people do
what people do and if different people
were involved you probably have
different actions taken now a lot of
that takes place in a context a
political context budgetary context
state of the world context and so forth
but it seems to me that they have never
been more open to really good people
going down and helping out as I'm sure
other parts of the government are and if
you have the right kind of view and
mentality and capability then you have
the ability to actually change things
and so rather than to comment on the way
it is I think the more helpful thing is
to say how can we become involved to
change it to be more the way we think it
ought to be well in fact that was kind
of the comment is to generate a little
bit discussion and and perhaps some of
these people in this room
that back that direction III chat with
Dwayne Adams all the time so I think
that you have to realize those guys who
they're between you know they have to go
to a new kind of Congress now that's
very very different and tough on that
sort of stuff so they're in a bind but
that the whole general process of that
of the quick return the way it is an
industry if your stock shifts a little
bit and in the next three weeks that's
bad so you can't do any long-term
changes that may say I'll drop for a
while and I'll make it up later it's
just an allowable to the CEOs okay bar
Frankston despite Microsoft I'm not
going to defend Windows but I want to
try to understand is why Windows are
such a problem in that what you know if
you have to change the world all at once
and you can't coexist with what exists
you've got a problem the web is a great
example of independent of Windows it
adds great functional capability and
there are lots of examples are like
Andy's rollerblades people learning
AutoCAD or graphics systems and
interacting great examples where people
have decided it's worth investing major
amounts of time to learn new paradigms
and new systems it doesn't mean they
give up the rest that is sort of why do
you real problems in getting you know do
you really feel like to change all the
world at once or what he promised to get
people to try out pilots or new ideas
sort of an industry or the the world at
large that's the only way I can see is
you have to get pilots operating and
there has to be some kind of conscious
pursuit of that future that you can't
really guarantee it is there but say
look I was gonna comment I mean I speak
on notes as I mentioned and trying to
get people to adopt that at similar
barriers again far from perfect but it
had a certain utility which some people
eventually found
but I just interesting learning examples
of really trunk sort of pilots and that
kind in new systems I mean I it's not
think it's worthwhile commenting at
length on it might but I think my main
point is that I think ms-dos got
millions of people used to as a normal
mode of interaction to something that
would have been barf tat in the in the
mid-60s but they didn't know that they
could interact better with the machine
and so it really set a low standard just
like television sets a low standard if
you don't know what theater can do
you're never going to find out by
watching television right that's the
problem and so it's not that you can't
do other kinds of things but for
instance if if any of them this let's
put Apple in there as well because the
you know from the standpoint that we're
talking about the the Apple interface
isn't any better than ms-dos and windows
I mean it's their basic food part and
parcel of monolithic I think for
instance if you wanted to put an angle
bar D and scheme in your application in
the Apple or Windows user interface it's
almost impossible to do because the
theory of interaction is buried so
deeply in there that you can't say okay
I want to interact in a different way
and yet in any reasonable
object-oriented implementation of these
things as in fact there was at Xerox
PARC you could sit down and design your
own interactive skin effect NLS which
Doug probably didn't mention had this
interesting thing where they actually
you could drive the user in in any part
of the system you could make up a new
user interface if you wanted to
experiment they had this grammar driven
so you could you could put in an
interface grammar yourself and use it to
drive other Drive commands if you were
experimenting so was it was a nope what
I would think of as an open system as
opposed to it didn't force the user to
go just the way it did it was actually
extensible in some very interesting ways
I probably have never even shown that in
a talk because it's it's more complex
than the other stuff
but it's it's interesting when he was
telling us about this sort of emergence
of small talk there well what do you
think we've encapsulated that all
another screw in to augment and now
we've got a small talk
encapsulation package that gives you
very flexible kind of interfacing that
you can you can go conventional if you
want to put you can ship but anyway it's
a I sort of take my hat off to Alan
about providing that way the small talk
I get to listen to I get to listen to a
number of researchers complain that the
development groups or the users in
general aren't willing to adopt their
ideas sometimes I ask these people to
look at their own desk and ask how
willing are they to say I want to be the
first user on this floor of bubble
memory instead of magnetic disk I've
just abandoned you know the C compiler
because you know I just heard about
iPhone and I think it's really wonderful
when I want to try it I don't hear that
very often from people and they ought to
accept the idea that the rest of the
world thinks that that they're not
different from the rest of the world
they're thinking the same way
Samuel ed up Stein with Sense Media Net
it was kind of a setup here and then the
question and I guess I'm young enough to
not totally believe that there isn't any
validity to the conspiracy theory that
Ted was referring to the other day and
things are pretty screwed up if you look
at what was going on 20 years ago and a
little bit longer and I have to say that
you know I've had my own experience that
was mentioned earlier today about not
being able to turn in a laser printed
report for the excuse that I was given
was because well the computer wrote this
and for this English class you have to
write this and and and I and I have to
say that when we're looking at the big
picture here I find that in my own
personal case in others others like me
with a very few exceptions of actively
searching out the people that are up on
these on the stage here and others like
you and finding this knowledge and
trying to do something with it the
current educational system in this
country seems to be doing a really good
job of helping to create these and
accrete these established self interests
which seem to prevent the dissemination
of this information and also seem to
encourage this well if it takes more
than five minutes don't waste your time
to create this environment how can we
how do you have any recommendations or
suggestions on how we can restructure
improve modify the established
educational system so that access to the
information that you're talking about
and is available to people that want to
do things with it one of the things that
Alan mentioned was he he held up in a
slide the book the molecular biology of
the G and I find this very funny if I
had to name four books I would name that
that did it for me
to basically set my career the first one
was computer lib dream machines the next
one was the medical molecular biology of
the gene the other two which I kind of
do together were Newman and spruill and
Foley and Van Damme and you know at this
point I have the last one which I just
read a few years ago which is a really
good one was the decline and fall of the
American programmer by by yordan Edward
yrden and this is also really good
reading but these are the kinds of
things that have allowed me to build up
a career around this and other people
too often at the expense in spite or
maybe despite of their academic
career how can we integrate these things
together so that they don't seem to be
so conflicting just just a quickie is
that just looking back to me one of the
paradoxes is that I think we made a
complete mistake when we were doing the
interface at Parc because we assumed
that the kids would need would need an
easy interface because we're gonna try
and teach them the program and stuff
like that but in fact the kids are the
ones that are willing to put hours into
getting really expert at things you know
they'll spend hours shooting baskets
they'll spend hours learning to hit
baseballs learning to ride bikes and now
on video games the amount I have a four
year old nephew who is really incredible
and he could use NLS fantastically if it
were available he would be flying
through that stuff because his whole his
whole thing is to become part of the
system he's interacting with and so if
it had that perspective I would have
designed a completely different
interface for the kids one in which the
how you became expert was much more
apparent than what I did so I I'm sorry
for what I did wait wait before you
rephrase it let me point out you're
stuck with it you know that that Allen
actually and popper actually did do a
very wise thing which was to focus on
kids because not only do they have the
time to learn weird and strange new
things they love doing it and that
counts for a lot the design of media as
soon as you establish premises you
pretty much lock it on track for example
the time slot determines the system we
call television once you have the time
slot and commercial television the rest
is given forget it similarly once you
have the curriculum
plus the implicit necessity of keeping
the dance cards of all those teachers
filled in other words it's it's a system
for employment of teachers and so they
have to have that each teacher has to
have an excuse for what he's doing all
the time then basically you have the
educational system as we now know it so
if so what you what you as I heard your
question Sam and by the way Sam and I go
back to when he was 12 if I heard your
correction your question correctly you
said how can we fix the educational
system as we now know it and of course I
think that's a contradiction in terms
the the point is to get rid of what is
in the way and that is the curriculum
and that is the that is the guaranteed
guaranteed employment for teachers
because that essentially is what is in
the way of the students if we could have
a system for example where you simply
say to a number of 14-year olds right
now we say them you must sit here for
four years in during the Duke of history
the mistress of mathematics and there
that and whatever you dislike about them
because they will fix your point of view
education is a process of ruining
subjects for you and the last subject to
be ruined determines your profession so
the point is that that and each each
subject is personified with the face of
this local ogre or perhaps in some cases
wondrous person who then represents that
subject and you never find out that
every subject has something in it of
interest to you every subject can can be
something that you take you to your
heart I thought I hated history I
thought I hated mathematics because of
the people I encountered and so some
other way around I would like to see a
school system where you simply say to
the kids at 14 not you have to sit here
for four years enduring and enduring and
enduring and being endangered and and
and insulted but rather you can get out
of here as soon as you fulfill as soon
as you present for for examination any
of these 80 mini courses any 80 of these
thousand mini-courses on this sheet you
can take more if you want and learn more
before we send you out there have your
choice then I think we would see real
motivation because right now there's no
way students can exercise initiative
except a if they're male disobeying B if
they're female getting pregnant and and
and C totally obeying and out doing
whatever the teacher wants which is done
by very few whereas all the other
systems that all systems are based on
initiative it week if we give people a
way to learn by initiative then we'd fix
the problem but nobody wants to do that
yeah that was what my question is more
directed not at the technology but at
the current system and how can we make
it more conducive to bringing people
online and getting the kids involved
what it's like cops need criminals you
know so it's it's a very complex thing
see more and I see more and I were in
Washington yesterday morning talking to
two congressional committees about just
this problem and of course both of us
were conscious of the irony that we were
we were actually talking to the the
people who were in business to stay in
business and so the the interest in in
changing things in any big way it was
something that's very very far from what
what they're trying to do and that that
is true of the for instance the average
expenditure for children in the u.s. is
about 6500 dollars a year if you
multiply that out on a classroom you get
to around 185 to 200 thousand dollars a
classroom well those classrooms are not
receiving any where near 185 thousand or
$200,000 a classroom from half to
three-quarters is soaked up by a
bureaucracy that it never gets down to
the school or the kids or anything else
I think that is an enormous problem and
basically we said exactly what you're
saying is that the the problem is that
there is a curriculum and we invoked the
name of Montessori whose idea was is
that school should always be an extended
kindergarten and it's the job of the
people who design the kindergarten to
make what happens when you use it for
your own reasons
more interesting than then the regular
world is and that's what Montessori did
and I think that's an excellent way of
thinking of designing a learning system
did you suggest we're basically breaking
the curriculum up into small pieces and
the Montessori system it allows you to
do whatever you like so long as
whichever Mahdi's Korean story school
you use the same colors for the same
length or the same blocks so they have
it you put within a very constrained
world there and I think one of the
things I took out of your question which
is a Tele a good question is there are
four books which for you could have been
your education given a computer the
network and those four books you would
have been happy you would have been and
you would achieve a lot of things and
wasted a lot less time and I was right
you were you managed to find the
question is how can other people find
them for you but one of the things you
can say that should be a curriculum the
problem is the prompt the reason that I
feel that the curriculum won't go away
there was an e television program in
which the BBC took our they took for
poor scientists who had been denied
acceptance by the academic community
their papers haven't been published
these beautiful ideas wonderful ideas
were just outside they were just to
extrude to different and interesting and
what they did in fact was to show that
by the end of the program that they
would also total junk so the problem is
that if you don't have the curriculum
then you leave somebody it's like
throwing somebody out straight away you
say right guys you're here to be free to
learn and here's the net and basically
they might as well do that at home so
it's that you're really asking is there
a case from education in a sense of
leading somebody do you want to lead
somebody is there a sense for having
something which is established as being
reasonable for people to spend it spend
their formative years studying and your
problem is that it takes too long to get
really good ideas into that now people
are looking back at the things that that
Ted said and said hey that's cool that
should be taught really early on that
should happen so first grade but it's
taken a long time for people to do that
it's good it's a filtration process that
if you leave people to look at all the
information you also want to lead them
and say hey this is really interesting
and sometimes it seems that the
situation's we've got just
the mechanism we have for filtering this
and reviewing it just takes generations
now that my only suggestion for if we
want to filter change that filtering
system in some cases for example with
computing we can move to a biological
model so you can leave while your kin oh
you're programming people around and you
let people to a few projects and hey you
give them CPU power and if they make
something which demonstrably works and
bubbles and enthuses people and now
you've got the net you can actually use
biological methods in some cases you
can't do it for learning good history
but but in some cases you can use
biological methods and get a faster time
turnaround because you can use computing
for advanced computing into whole it
occur of people out there who
participate now during the hours of
darkness to try these things out you
know I just occurred to me that giving
its equal time is not fair because in
the same amount of time he can say so
much more I just want to say that there
all these things are very relevant to
look at about how you educate children
and that they can learn more and
differently but the thing is that the
institution of Education is not likely
be changed by the children be changed by
the people that are there in the current
state in order to change it and we can't
wait for the 20 years or so till those
children are out integrated into society
where they have the rules that they can
start making changes that that changed
driving things about both world events
etc and the technology are moving too
fast so we have we're just faced for the
fact we have to learn a better way to
shift organizations with the people that
are in them now so that's that's really
why you need a strategy court and it's
exciting to think of what the children
can become and to flourish etc but the
the daunting problem that I think we
really have to face is how do you deal
with the change of the adult world thank
you and also thanks for the last 20
years guys
my name is Ricky Goldman Siegel I've met
some of you already before from the
University of British Columbia the
Faculty of Education but I'm not going
to pursue the issue of education because
I so vehemently disagree with some of
the things that you just said Ted but
you've heard my story before with that
and I well I remind you is that a how
many of us I guess raise your hands how
many of us would have been here if it
weren't for one fabulous or several
fabulous people in your life who
inspired you and were those people your
teachers if they were I know they were
for me well it's not just the teacher
but it's within but they had to perform
within a system well perhaps I'm gonna
I'm gonna respond to leave Sprouse
notion that science or scientific
investigation is as relational and
interactive thing that actually could
happen in the schools much more and I'm
gonna do that and in a way as a sort of
summation perhaps as well because we're
at the end of the conference and what
I'd like to know is what each of you
learn from each other that you didn't
know before you got here or and in some
sense what you think your biggest
similarities are but also what do you
think your biggest differences are
because I think within that we sort of
know where some aspects of the field are
moving so I guess that's my question
I learned that Ted Nelson and I are
alike because we both have purple socks
and I'm not wearing mine but he's
wearing his and I learned that Alan Kay
actually did believe that kids would be
working together using their Dinah books
over the network and I apologized out
and I should have known that you would
have believed that I don't I don't want
to be only facetious but that's a rather
difficult question to deal with so I
think that most importantly I have I
wouldn't say I learned sort of bits of
information I experienced I guess a
reaffirmation of the importance of the
ideas and the importance of the
scientists who have been pursuing them
sometimes with reward and honor and
sometimes without but that didn't matter
because it's the ideas that were
important and continue to be important
and so what was most important for me
was the reaffirmation of that community
well I learned that everybody here is
more idealistic than I thought well no
in some cases some people couldn't be
more idealistic I'm just glad to see all
these old characters still hanging in
there
I guess one thing which actually vint
cerf pointed out at a similar sort of
mix of people said that one thing that
he pointed out everybody had in common
with was persistence that having ideas
and then just an even know telling
people telling you not to do hanging
onto it and going and I'm being really
stubborn and doing it even though told
not to and even though nobody's giving
you money to do it and what have you
that seems to be something which
everybody has to have an Italian common
or either it was I don't know where
there's been something intrinsic to a
sort just with the the idea is sort of
our ideas which once they got you they
don't let go apart from that I have
gifts where it's really pretty amazingly
heterogeneous and the differences are
part of them sort of every in everything
else what am I supposed to do if it's to
say goodbye well I I enjoyed it
thoroughly and it sort of opens my eyes
to something that that I was always
embarrassing it's that that I've I sort
of lost track of a lot of things that
are going on that are important and that
I wish I could keep track of so maybe
I'll turn over new me for something or
me divide my time differently but anyway
I heard this remarks about idealistic
old farts and I thought okay that's why
I have to say something
anyway thank you for the meeting there's
nothing to say after that I guess you
know what I thought I learned is once
again there's people who are laying out
broad visions and there are engineers
who were building guts and I'm led back
to my preference for the engineers and
I'm glad to see that Bush was one and I
realized this is one of the great
engineering institutions of the world
and I thank it for running the meeting
sorry about that
sorry Robert I'll promise to do better
oh boy don't like to cross that guy I
want to thank our wonderful speakers and
wonderful audience for a really amazing
event in my life and I'd like to invite
any of you who would like to hear Ted do
a reprise of his wonderful talk of
yesterday and for the rest of you
Godspeed and see you at the next one
[Applause]
you